ومنذ بدا الحرب تحاول القوات الروسيه دون
توقف السيطره على جبهه بخمه دون جدوى
اين تقع
شمالي مقاطعه دونيتك في اقليم دوماس
شرقي اوكرانيا
600 كيلو متر عن العاصمه
في قلب الهجوم الروسي في دونيتك وتعرضت
خلال الاشهر اللاحقه لمحاوله اقتحام عديده
احبطتها القوه الاوكرانيه
تكتسي اهميه رمزيه عاليه بعد الانسحاب من
خارج كيف يدفع الجيش الروسي بكل الثقله
مستعينا بمليشيا فاجنر وجنه الاحتياط
بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه ايضا
حسنا للدفاع عن باقي مدندنيسك منها تشن
فرق المدفعيه والصواريخ ضرباته على
المواقع الروسيه المختلفه
لمناقشه ما يجري على الارض بتفصيل اكبر
ينضم الينا من جديد مراسلنا من موسكو امين
درغامي ومن كرامات تورسك مراسلنا عمر
الحاج لنسمع الى الروايتين الروسيه
والاكرانيه واتابع معك امين كنا نتحدث عما
يجري فيران ولكن الارض ما يجري على الارض
هو الفيصل هنا ما هي الروايه الرسميه
بالنسبه للمخمت همم تحديدا
نعم بعد ان كانت قوات فاجنر قد اعلنت امس
على لسان مؤسسها يفقيني برجوجن على انها
سيطرت على بلده كليشيفكا التي تعد احدى
اهم ضواحي مدينه باخموت اليوم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قالت بان بان المتطوعين في
اشاره طبعا الى فاجنر اضافه الى قوات
المدفعيه والقوات الانزال الروسيا الجوي
تمكنت من السيطره على كليشيف ايضا ما زالت
هناك تدور معارك من اجلها تقدم للسيطره
على الطريق الرابط بين بخمه وهو لاربما
المسعى الذي تسير باتجاه القوات الروسيه
الان في محاوله لعزل المدينه من همم ثلاثه
اتجاهات بعد طبعا السيطره على سوليدار واي
السيطره على بلده صول التي لا تبعد عن
سوليدار لكن في الحقيقه على الارض
باريس خلال اليومين الماضيين هو ما يجري
الان في مقاطعه زبروجيا ليلى عندما كان
همم الحديث عن اقليم دمباز همم يمكن القول
بان الاحداث هناك في زبروجا طفت على السطح
خلال اليومين الماضيين عبرا ما تقول
القوات الروسيه انه عمليه عسكريه واسعه
تشلها في عدد من المحاور بمقاطعه هذه
الجبهه التي ربما كانت جامده خلال الاشهر
السته الماضيه همم المعارك هناك كانت همم
تقريبا همم شبه منعدمه باستثناء بعض القصف
المتبادل بين الجانبين خاصه في محيط محطه
اليوم بحسب السلطات الروسيه في المقاطعه
هناك هجوم على عدد من المحاور ابرازها
مدينه تاريخ اوف وحديث عن ان خط الجبهه او
خط الدفاع الاوكراني
راجع لاربعه كيلومترات بعد سيطره القوات
الروسيه على بلدات مهمه حول مدينه اريح خذ
هذه المدينه التي لا تبعد الا بنحو 35 كلم
عن عاصمه مقاطعه زاباروجا اي مدينه
زاباروجه هناك من قرا في هذا تحرك العسكري
اللافث في الحقيقه محاوله خاطفه من قبل
القوات الروسيه بعد ان همم ذهبت كلها
الانظار والاهتمام العسكري لنقل الاوكراني
الى محور بخموت الى بعض المحاور في قيم
دنياك ومنافقين دون مباراه عمومانا الان
ربما القوات الروسيه تحاول القيام بعمليات
هجوميه خاطفه همم السيطره على عدد من
المناطق باتجاه مدينه